So the album comes out.
I mean, look, you you get to this space
of amazing clarity.
Holy shit, you dropped this album, Life
changing album after going through the
meditation process.
The first proof of concept is the
product that was developed during or
while or after.
So the light bulb now that goes off is
what?
Nah, I just my take was.
This is what it feels like when you
when you are really in tune with
yourself, really in tune with God, when
you're when when the noise can't enter.
You know what I mean? This is what it
feels like. And even to this day, bro,
it's like. It's like it's funny because
I find myself talking about meditation
a lot, but it's not like.
But it's only because in conversation I
meet people and they're telling me
about, like, things that I went
through. And I'm just telling you this
is what I did. But the interesting
thing is it's like it got me to a to a
place where my lowest point is so much
higher than what my what my lowest
point used to be. But I will say, I'm
not a person that that currently to
this day just wakes up and meditate
every day. I think about Rick, like
Rick Rubin, when I watch these Rick
Rubin interviews and he just feels like
a just a sensei master and just I just
imagine him waking up every day and
just meditating three times a day and
maybe he doesn't. But it's my
impression of him. And I realized that
like, oh man, people probably have that
impression about me because I've spoken
about it. They probably think I'm on
some like. But the truth is no, it's
like I, I use meditation now as, like I
say it as like an emergency break glass
thing where it's like if I'm feeling
high anxiety, you know what I mean?
For whatever's happening in my life,
which is not often right now, but, but
if something's coming up where it's
like, I'm feeling anxiety about this,
like this is, then I'll use it as like,
let me get back to a balanced state.
But I'm not currently in a space where
it's like I'm meditating every day,
boom, boom, boom. No, I feel like that
year or two year stretch that I was on
it, it gave me a nice like, like boost
in my life to where it's like now I'm
kind of coasting. And I do believe that
even in this state right now that I'm
in, if I meditated every day, like I
feel like I'd be a superhero, you know
what I mean? Because I feel like
everything would just off me.
Like water. It's repelling.
It's repelling, right? Yes.
When you say anxiety, do you feel like
it's the anxiety from the business?
Is the anxiety from the pressure that
you sometimes put on yourself?
Is the anxiety from household family?
Yeah. Like, for instance.
Like like when I say like emergency
break glass situation, like there was a
time when my my first child was going
to be born and and the anxiety I felt
was more like it wasn't like, oh, I'm
about to have a kid. But it was
probably the culmination of all these
things. But I was also finishing an
album at that time.
We was doing the classes trying to
learn about like like the birthing
process and all of this boom boom.
So it was like it was one of those
moments where everything was kind of
like a lot was happening.
And, and, and that was like a moment
where I just needed to, you know,
before one of the classes that we had,
which I loved, those classes that we
took was called Hypno Babies.
I recommend that for anybody that's,
you know, hypno babies.
Basically, it's like a birthing class
that that, you know, first of all, I
think the first most important thing it
does is it prepares both.
Uh, parents for the realities or like.
Like the information that you might
need to arm yourself when you go into a
hospital room.
My babies came out. It was a shit show
around here.
It had me feeling prepared.
I was in there.
Yeah, I said I'll figure it out.
I came out. A lot of shit happened fast
too.
It worked, though, right?
I was at the doctor all the time, baby.
Coughing Doc was happening.
It's just a cough, all right.
No, no, no, no. Not that, though.
Not that.
I'll tell you what it was for me.
Okay? All right.
Man. How was. How was that guy?
Nah, me.
Too, though, By the way.
This is just scary.
Me, The birthing process after the
baby's out, they don't. They ain't got
nothing for you, okay?
This was like.
They have nothing to offer you.
After going through the the course of
the nine months. And, you know, when
you when.
That water breaks, this is what you need
to look at.
You there when water broke.
Yeah. I was downstairs.
Oh I mean yeah. Yeah, for sure.
For sure. No, no, no.
I didn't see it like a movie.
By the way. Okay. I was going to say.
No, no, no.
It wasn't no movie moment broke.
Oh, shit. No, no.
No, no. Gotcha. No, it was.
Uneventful. It's not like the movie.
Like, you know, the movies. They make
you feel like it's like a like a like
some sort of like.
Yeah, you got it. I'll get the car.
Yeah. No, it wasn't like that.
I get the car. No, you got the bag.
It's already packed by my door.
Yeah. No, no, none of that shit. None
of that. I was really downstairs, babe.
My water broke. Huh?
Huh? Yeah, that's where I was.